thank you
[Music]
when's the last time any of you guys
used Pandora I use it all the time dude
yeah even with the ads they have good
playlists I pay for it
how are you I'm just used to it a time
ago especially after Spotify did the
like once you find a song you like you
can go to that song's type of radio
Pandora's out for me that's true that
was the only thing left on Pandora that
was kind of useful right the only thing
is I've spent years on Pandora so all
the music that I liked and disliked I
just got a huge library for that channel
so
yeah maybe I should swap the bottom Pie
make sense Spotify is very useful though
compared to Pandora I pay for Pandora
how much is Pandora by the way I have no
idea
so Pandora's being sued right now I'm
leaving Pandora
you don't even know who's showing that
you should buy a group of comedians
um of which George Lopez is one of the
newest people to be added to that list
because Pandora has been streaming
comedy albums without having the rights
to do it they do do comedy yeah yeah
what they have to have rights to stream
[ __ ] you do but then I thought they paid
everybody they they're supposed to
but they didn't so the thing is usually
what they do is they'll deal with uh the
label and then whoever's under the label
then now they're just being streamed
whatever to get the whole like catalog
order they get the catalog you'll get
like a fraction of a penny or whatever
whatever uh amount of streams but people
like George Lopez and Lewis Black Andrew
Dice Clay they're all claiming they've
never received anything and Lou is black
as an example has said that he doesn't
even have a label that they contacted to
like sign the deal even though they're
saying like no we contacted all your
guys as people and we squirted out he's
like I own all my [ __ ] yeah so I would
be the person oh he's about to be Rich
As [ __ ] Yeah I'm glad I wonder how he
could prove how many streams you can see
it you can't you can see it's straight
up like how many planes yeah it'll be
like I think like his or someone's like
100 something thousand streams and yeah
they haven't gotten anything plus here's
another kicker you know how with music a
lot of people don't know that the writer
of the song is a separate entity
entirely than the person performing it
so you definitely have to like when you
ask permissions it kind of has to go to
both parties when you pay people
everyone's getting their share in comedy
a lot of these guys write their own
stuff so they're getting paid twice oh
that's sweet yeah
so if you wrote your own stand up they
have to treat you like a different guy
so those are two contracts those are two
people like writing credits and
Performing credits exactly yeah
so it's the same thing as like a rapper
that's you know so this is going to be
the nail in the coffin of Pandora that's
sort of what it looks like I had no idea
it was still even a thing I didn't
either as everyone on Spotify now I
think everybody I think so yeah yeah
he's actually used I heart he's like I
still use Winamp what the industry is
comparing this to is what happened to
Napster once the record label started
complaining about not being paid for
downloads they're looking at it that way
so if you see what happens in Napster
when that went down people stopped using
that too you know it was kind of that
was a nail in the coffin for that app
you know I really don't know any right
when he said Pandora I was like oh yeah
who the [ __ ] uses Pandora I think I
still got Pandora I haven't been using a
long time I still like I remember liking
it I just haven't used it in like years
probably I use Audible that's pretty new
audible's a [ __ ] sweet audible sweet
I don't gotta read books bro I also use
uh the the playlists that other people
make on YouTube Loop
for music wow that's not bad actually
yeah that's actually nice because you
don't have to worry about it just put it
on and then every once in a while you
can look it's like a music video it's
kind of interesting the mixes on YouTube
are pretty fire bro I stumbled upon like
these DJs well they'll play like
Japanese Funk and they'll do like a
whole like playlist and they're DJing
and that would be a video of them DJing
and it's like a two hour block and it's
so [ __ ] cool and you're just sitting
there watching the whole time all two
hours and I just got I got YouTube
premium recently that shit's so nice
honestly I'll [ __ ] with YouTube free
okay
there's no ads no ads bro it just keeps
playing you can like swipe up like on
your phone and it just it the video is
still in a little window so you can keep
doing it and then on top of that too
it's like uh like every thumbnail you
can pretty much hover over it and watch
the videos before even clicking it so
you can like preview everything I
thought regular YouTube did all right
but it would show like uh Snippets with
YouTube premium it'll be the whole video
wow I've watched whole videos
I like how I can swipe out or you can
just lock your phone and it's still
playing the noise dude mine still does
that it's uh it's the right now I think
they've been doing a promo where it's
like when you first sign up it's like
three months it's free yeah because I
got it because of Cobra Kai and then you
can watch if you want to watch like
movies and TV shows and [ __ ] too they
have a free it's free what's in the it's
a part of the service do they have
exclusive content on YouTube premium
they did I think they do but like
[ __ ] the one Steve wrote with Logan
Paul and [ __ ] like yeah if you were a
part of YouTube premium and [ __ ] or they
called it I don't even do it for the
[ __ ] extra [ __ ] I do it for the
[ __ ] ad listness yeah once there's no
ads you're just like this is a totally
different experience even even if it's
five seconds it's still just nice
clicking on a video and it starts you're
like man I'm kind of sold on it and you
could even save videos for offline and
watch them later when there's no
reception
Oh Oh I thought all those options were
regular YouTube because I've been on
YouTube Red for a minute so I have no
idea I think the cool this thing is like
how I can swipe up and start doing other
stuff on my phone and then the video
that's huge for me because I couldn't do
that before and now I'm constantly
watching like golf videos and stuff like
while I'm driving because my my
navigation's still open in the little
video oh the hot chick off that you
watch yeah I only watch hot dudes I sent
them some really good influencers too
yeah short skirts yeah her name is uh
Tiger Woods Rory McIlroy Colin murakawa
Brooks kepka
no yeah
I feel like a [ __ ] Boomer like last
week because uh so you know like when
usually they go oh like you hear an app
and even though like I'm not on Tick
Tock I know that's what the kids are on
or whatever right this this guy comes up
to me oh gotta take a picture with you
yeah of course he goes oh but it's this
app and I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
app so I guess there's this new app now
where um if Nick takes a picture of me
it takes a picture of him at the same
time so now the images is two people and
you get to see two people's faces on
both sides of the phone and I was like
is this the new kid [ __ ] no what the
[ __ ] man that's pretty cool Instagram
added that I think I got like uh you
know when like Instagram posts like a
story and YouTube and like shows the new
[ __ ] I just saw that like so I can take
a picture of the wall but it's also
gonna be showing like oh oh I got you
I'm gonna do it right now you have it
what is that wait but you gotta take a
picture of you too though oh no no this
is just the mirror thing wow what a
boomer it's an app it's an actual like
[ __ ] new kid app yeah it's a new kid
app there's an app where you can record
simultaneously
cool
oh God look at Nick dude oh yeah what is
that it's on Instagram it's like part of
their thing now okay it's like we're
FaceTiming look at that huh
who the [ __ ] hey Perfect all right what
nationality both of those are the
ugliest people I've seen in my whole
life dude the guy on top is like Bart
bro the guy on top is Bart yeah this
one's Bart for sure dude look how thick
his neck is
this is an ethnic background as Goomba
I'm gonna do it to Joe right now ready
Joe look at me
okay
oh [ __ ] okay hold on hold on I got you
hold on wait wait I gotta there it is
there just one two oh [ __ ] I'm so bad
oh my
God JK sorry bro
yeah
um
yo this is just hey Fat Joe Fat Joe dude
fat Joe's the best the funny the funny
reality about apps is that like with
kids is that they're just gonna
continually try to use the app that the
adults are not using like instinctively
you know that's like my generation
Facebook I feel like yeah we just
stopped using Facebook oh hell yeah it's
extra old it's unusable now I can't say
anything on there I found out from uh
nephews and nieces that you know the
whole tide pod scare yeah that was the
ultimate like
um like kid troll yeah so like us as
adults believed it yeah we're like oh my
God they're all typable man these kids
are crazy for them it's been a troll the
whole time like they can't believe these
guys think we eat yeah like nobody
really did it yeah I bet there's some
kids that are eating yeah
afterwards they were a diet or something
yeah
like spitting it out and [ __ ] but they
weren't really doing it yeah did the uh
your Disney twin with Joe
I've never even seen Frozen
[Music]